we are talking today about how to make
content that touches people's hearts we
talk about emotional commitment the
thing I struggled the most with and
we're going to go and look at some of my
old videos and be embarrassed by how bad
it was at the start so just like your
success can be other people's
inspiration how much you sucked and kept
going can also be other people's
inspiration that's the goal for today's
session so emotional commitment I've
never even heard of this term before
this is one of the most important
changes that I made as a content creator
that started to make an impact and it
came from my agent Steve now this is a
picture of me and Steve when we went up
in New York and my first videos weren't
that great and you can go back and you
can watch and this is my very first
video and in my first video I thought I
had to be professional I thought I had
to be in a suit and sit down and have it
professionally filmed and memorize my
lines and be perfect and scripted and
this took two days to make and I had
three comments in that first year right
my mom my sister and this guy ABC TV ads
so in one year my first video going up I
only had three comments and two of them
were from my family it was really rough
and I made all the mistakes that we all
make and so the goal was something like
this and movement makers is to try to
help you guys shortcut the path so that
you don't have to take as long as I did
to get there and so emotional commitment
behind the content made a huge huge huge
huge huge difference you guys are you're
you know what you're talking about
you're experts right you've been through
something and that something can help
Inspire and serve a lot of people the
problem is and the problem for me and in
watching your videos the problem for you
is you're saying a lot of times the
right words and we're so focused on
saying the right words but there's no
emotion behind the words and if there's
no emotion behind the words then people
won't follow along they won't pay
attention they won't take notice they
won't do the action and your content
your channel won't grow so even more
important than the perfect words that
you're saying is how emotionally
connected are you to the thing that
you're saying it's the old Maya Angelou
quote the people remember how you made
them feel right that's what they
remember the most not what you said but
how you made them feel and if there's no
emotion behind the words you're saying
then they won't feel anything different
so
uh Steve had just incredible patience
with me for some reason he just loved me
for some reason I guess uh because it
took me a long time to get halfway
decent on camera on videos and um yeah I
must have been his little Pet Project or
charity case to help me get going so
emotional commitment is what we want to
start paying attention to in our content
all right deep breath let's start
looking at some old Evan Carmichael
videos and I will I will give myself
some coaching uh and look back so I
started in 2009
okay and and I don't we don't have to go
all the way back you guys can look at
that if you want this is 2011 now this
is my third year of making content okay
so it's not just like my first video
going up this is Evan in year three of
making content okay so first I'm making
all the classic mistakes right I have my
intro coming on as the first thing I
thought I had to be fancy and
professional and show off right so you
know we're not doing this no fancy
intros
all right
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Kevin in today's
video okay so already you know there's
no energy
hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan right I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my readers Ina Oro who is asking about
the videos that I make how I make them
and why I make them so specifically
wrote in asking hi Evan you're just a
great guy for being consistent with your
messages thank you
I have two questions for you one in what
way do these messages you send to people
positively impact your business I mean
economically or financially and two do
you have people working on them and
sending them out for you or do you have
to write and work on people's questions
new ideas continuously when do you have
the core of your business to take care
of as well I want to say something like
this but I need to know if it's worth my
while thanks and Oro
so a couple of ideas here for you on on
how I create these videos
um most of the videos that I create come
from reader questions just like this
just like the one that that you wrote in
I don't make money from these videos
sometimes they're sponsored by a
corporate partner but most of the videos
are not sponsored I do
the videos because I really like helping
out entrepreneurs and this is what gets
me excited okay so thoughts what are
your thoughts on this video pop it pop
it in the chat love to see what's coming
up Chrissy says it's adorable Ida says
nice computer or is a computer oh well
this is 2011. that's an old school
computer uh is that Windows 95 I have no
idea uh how are you making money back
then so I I mean I wasn't at the
beginning right I had some some sponsors
on videos but like I said I just I love
doing it you know like I'm three years
in making content just because I love
doing it now I had I had sold my
business already a different business my
first company and I had some money so it
wasn't that I needed this to necessarily
pay off right away
um but I just love doing it right
they're like I'm how do you keep going
even on year three when you're
struggling and not getting traction and
not making any money well just because I
love actually doing it your smile is
underutilized no energy says Michael shy
Evan low energy compared to current
event it's it's somewhat flat that's
very kind Denise I'd say it's very flat
compare it to you now but still genuine
honest and real so this is this is the
difference right
uh Izumi says I don't feel Evan that I
feel now critiques monotone no energy no
powerful intro statement yeah so to
Denise's point right it's still genuine
honest and real this is where
this is where a lot of you are stuck and
I think honestly a lot of you are
already better than this
I'm still the same guy
and I still have the same a lot of same
information to share I mean I've
hopefully learned a little bit in the
past what 11 years but but
I'm still I know a lot at 2011 knows a
lot 2011 Evan 2011 Evan knows a lot and
you guys know a lot and you're already
better than me probably in this but this
is what a lot of people's videos look
like when they're getting into thought
leadership you like read somebody's
question and then you just start talking
and sharing and helping but because it's
flat and monotone people won't listen to
the actual content
and so I'm still the same guy this is
still me I have I have less hair but
more emotional commitment
foreign
that's the difference right so we don't
have to watch this whole thing we'll go
we'll go to the next one Zane says Evan
isn't bouncing bouncing helps
okay so
2012. we're a full year later now and
now also just quick update these are not
the old thumbnails I used I don't even
have thumbnails back then we've just
been going back and updating all of our
old thumbnails so let's see how good
2012 I've been another year of practice
four years in now on my YouTube journey
and I'd love to see some comments down
as well as you start watching what do
you think
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my Facebook viewers Jasmine who wrote in
a really really long message it's almost
a page here of a message I won't read
the whole thing but the Crux of it is uh
I know in my heart and mind that it
takes money to make money how do you
make money if you don't have the finance
system to back it up and that's the key
thing I wanted to address today
I want to get that notion out of your
head it doesn't take money to make money
it's not about how many resources you
have it's about how resourceful you can
be so if you look at all the the famous
successful entrepreneurs especially in
the past a lot of them didn't come from
wealthy backgrounds a lot of them didn't
have huge investors they bootstrapped
their way up you know they they make the
tough decisions and did not go out and
spend a lot of money and the key here is
not spending until you're making money
okay so we don't have to watch the whole
thing quick thoughts better energy
better better lighting more comfortable
I'd say better you look more confident
more energy see more confident more
comfortable
uh still pitching in the beginning a
little more energy and you got right
into it yeah so I mean this is still I
think pretty bad if you if you're
comparing it to 2011 Evan then maybe
it's a little bit better but in terms of
emotional commitment
it still sucks there's still there's
still no real energy behind this I'm
just answering the question and again I
just didn't know this is just part of if
I knew and I had something to work on I
could make it better I thought here's
this person's question I'm going to
answer the question and and hopefully it
helps and move on to the next thing and
so there you know I might be a little
more practiced or comfortable in front
of the camera with an extra year under
my belt but in terms of the emotional
commitment behind the words it's not
really there and it's funny that you
know I'm watching back this is now 10
years ago that that whole line that I
used about it's about how resourceful
you are instead of how many resources
you have it's still something I'll say
today
it's like 20 20 2012 Evan was was a
pretty smart guy you know he had some
information there but but the delivery
still needed uh a lot of work and so
this you know again I think a lot of you
are already still ahead in your delivery
over 2012 Evan and you definitely have
the information inside your head and so
it's how do we bring
uh more energy out Zan saying how would
the emotionally committed Evan say today
well this is it like look at look at the
look at the range that I'm using now
look at the energy into look at me
laughing at myself now this is I mean if
you've seen in my videos on stage or how
we even start Movie Makers there's a lot
more energy just go watch any of my
videos where especially the espresso
ones where I'm talking it's it's just
being able to tap into that emotional
range instead of just being trapped in
your logical brain because the content
is the same it's the wrapping around it
I said something that Zen like there
he's going ooh the content is not that
different but the packaging and how I
wrapped it
has changed dramatically which allows it
to hit people in a stronger way
um Denise said so I thought this was
pretty good I need new definition for
emotional delivery and impact yeah and
we're so worried about saying the right
words
you're so worried about getting the
perfect script it's like the script is
not the thing the emotional commitment
you have behind the words that you're
saying is the thing that will move the
needle for people
and so every time we try to learn a new
skill the emotional commitment will
probably drop down a bit every time we
give you a new structure to say hey like
try to start with a powerful opinion now
you're so stressed out it wasn't
powerful opinion did it get the powerful
opinion right it might did that work or
not right and so it's okay to take a
little bit of a step back every time
we're trying to learn something new but
I want this to be something that that
you're constantly looking at to improve
your content in watching yourself back
to say how how emotionally committed was
I to that message that was I feeling it
more than was I worried about saying the
right words
the daily to do and not to-do list now
I've done the to-do list a lot of times
the not to do part of it though was the
interesting thing that I had to really
think about and took me a lot longer
than expected so let me start with the
easy stuff the to-do list so I'm going
to walk you through what I do every day
every morning uh and and the different
calendars that I have and I'm going to
take it deeper than I've ever taken it
and any any presentation or speech my
morning starts with no alarm
so the to do is no alarm
and I'll usually go to bed at the same
time you go to bed around 11 and read
and then fall asleep maybe 11 30. but I
wake up with no alarm and I haven't
woken up to an alarm
I don't know maybe in a decade uh now if
I'm speaking and I have to be on stage
in the morning or traveling or something
then sure but day to day no alarm I just
basically let my body get the rest of
the needs so yesterday I woke up at
eight something this morning I woke up
at five something
I wake up when my body wakes up some
nights I need more rest some nights I
don't need as much rest and so I get up
right and so
um I I delayed the start of my day where
nothing really happens has to happen
until 10 o'clock so that I can get the
sleep that I need in my life Susie says
absolutely agree with that I mean I work
for everybody but telling you what works
for me
next the first thing I do after I wake
up
is intention for the day
I wake up you know I got lines on my
face I got stuff in my eyes you know
what day is it I don't even remember
what is my intention for the day this is
the first thing that I do so I go to the
bathroom and in the bathroom I'm looking
at my calendar for what's happening
today
and setting the intention okay oh today
what day is today it's Thursday it's
public facing day what's my intention I
have movement makers up first it's
amazing this is going to be great what's
my intention I want to serve the people
here in this group I want to help I want
to try to get the things that are inside
my head and and put into your head so
you can then spread your message out and
get it to other people's heads and so
what's the intention and different days
have different intentions for me even
even inside a day you might have
different intentions the the background
on my cell phone you probably you
probably can't see it too small but it
says remember your intention
remember you're it's a constant
reminders news what is my intention for
the day for this moment for right now
because if you wake up most people wake
up like an accident with zero intention
and you got hopes and dreams and
Ambitions and something inspires you and
you hope that makes a difference and it
might but we forget our intention
so when you live in intentional day it's
totally different than when you're
living an accidental day
next 30 breaths and then cold 10 cold
splashes on my face so 30 breaths is is
a Wim Hof style so it'll be
foreign
like that 30 breaths just to start
getting some airflow going and then I I
will take the coldest water while I'm
doing that I have water on running and
I'll just then splash it on my face
just to wake up like good morning we set
Our intention no time like the present
to go kick us off let's go so 30 breaths
10 cold splashes every day then water
the goal is to drink one of these a day
I am about here since I woke up at five
so I'm about halfway through
a gallon a day you're dehydrated when
you wake up it's really hard to have
energy when you don't have water inside
you so super quick water then I do an
Eda scan and I don't know if you guys
have heard of this this was introduced
to me by Deepak Chopra when I did an
interview with him
I don't know about a month ago or a
couple weeks ago on the channel where
it's part of the Fitbit watch so Nina
and I both have the Fitbit watch and you
basically cover it with your hand and it
tracks your heartbeat
and the the shortest Eda scan you can do
is two minutes for them and your the
goal is just to calm your mind relax
just sit down and
have intention and and just let go of
Whatever anxiety you might have and then
it'll track your heartbeat over the
course so I can easily get my heartbeat
down from you know 80 90 to 60.
in two minutes
so every morning I just do a quick Eda
scan
um to remind myself then I take the dogs
out get some sun get some sun on your
face it makes a huge huge huge
difference having a dog forces that
but what on days where I don't take the
dogs out in the morning or don't get sun
I don't have as much energy
there's just something like getting some
even here in Toronto when it's it's
freezing and cold in Canada and it's
starting to get a little bit nice now
but even in the winter just getting
outside getting some fresh air even just
that idea of getting out of your your
home
changes the energy State when you come
back
for anybody who works at home this is
going to be really hard is that you
there's no separation between
waking up to then going to work
things blur too much so having some kind
of routine to make that transitioner
easier you're basically leaving the home
and coming back and when you're coming
back you're getting ready to go work
sun is vitamin D says Frank I also
stretch so this is going to be me every
time I'm outside because I'm standing on
the trampoline all day long and I'm
doing 20 to 40 000 jumps a day my
hamstrings get super tight so anytime
I'm outside with the dogs I'm stretching
out my hamstrings so if you see me doing
this I'm okay just getting my stretches
in
um exercise so then I'll go for a walk
or a run sometimes with Nina or
sometimes if she's not awake then I'll
go learn so this morning was no nina
time she woke up late so I went by
myself went for a run and I'll if I'm
with Nina then we'll we'll usually do a
walk they'll be you know 45 minutes and
we talk with the dogs if I'm not with
Nina I'm I'm walking faster or running
although Nina can walk really really
really fast for a little person she
walks faster than me so that's that's
epic and I usually have the top 10 rules
in my in my ear as I'm running or
walking getting outside getting some
exercise learning as well right what
what is the thing that gets you inspired
motivated confident ready for action
bold courageous and then doing that
thing in the morning
so I I make my videos still for me I
consume my video still for me and I want
that in my life because
uh so today was Tom bilyu today I was
listening to Tom billiard and every time
I listen to Tom Billy you I get a little
more bold a little more courageous a
little more spark and so not just hoping
that it happens designing and
Engineering it into your day every day
demanding it
uh and then the latest finish is 10. so
all that has to happen by 10. that can
go super quick
or it can take more time again depends
on when I wake up so from if I wake up
at eight something I go super fast
through but it still gives me the time
to get through it because I don't have
to be done until 10.
this morning I woke up at five something
super easy to get through all this stuff
but I don't set a start time for
anything
because I don't know when I'm gonna wake
up so there's not the pressure if I have
to be outside by X time
I have to be done by 10 and there's
there's no situation where I'm not
waking up
by 10. I can't sleep in that long uh so
this is pretty much
every day
it's pretty much every day
um weekdays for sure most weekends every
day
that's my morning routine my to-do list
the daily routine I'm not gonna go like
step by step through this if you want to
go deeper we can on these even questions
but this is what a weekday typically
looks like wake up the one routine that
you just saw 10 o'clock I'm done right
10 o'clock I have to be done that's
music and daily websites music like why
we have Zan here before you guys get on
because look at me so excited music is
the fastest way to change your state
right and and
Alex comes on and starts singing I can
see clearly now so then Zayn starts
playing the song Tess says she loves
Calypso so Zayn starts putting on that
music for her Zen knows I like salsa so
then he plays that like when you when
you play music that you like that would
force you like Nina was doing her
gardening stuff I was sitting here or
standing here salsa comes on we have to
go dance right there are songs that when
they come on it forces you to get up and
move
and when you do that and make it a part
of your morning routine it can change
your entire outlook on the days if I
don't have the music I'm just not as
energetic not as ready to go so what I
do is I have it says Daily website says
25 to 30 websites that I load every day
just to check in on things the first
website is my playlist so I have a
believe playlist on my YouTube channel
it's it's open it's free you guys can
look at it if you want it doesn't really
matter what's on my playlist it's more
what's on your playlist what would you
want to have there and you could do that
today design your playlist so that
tomorrow when you wake up you can just
put it on and it will force you to get
out of your groggy state
because these are songs that would have
to make you get out of your chair think
of the songs that if they came on it
would get you out of your chair we all
have those start your day with it makes
a huge difference 10 30 to 1 3 125 is is
a work chunk and that depends on what
I'm doing for the day Thursday is public
facing day so this is this is why mover
makers is at 10 30.
it's no surprise that's why we're here
it's my work chunk number one so on
different days I have different tasks
but it's always these work chunks
130 to 155 I'm checking email and I'm
doing uh some Social Media stuff two
o'clock IG live uh or insiders group
live so that's my break in between of
like of my different work chunks
um then 2 30 to 255 and this is every
weekday this is Monday to Friday uh I'll
go out with Nina and we'll go right now
since it's getting warmer we'll just go
to the park take the dogs get some sun
we connect how was your morning because
I'm I'm pretty
locked in
for that morning right I'm doing
whatever work I need to be doing
um I'm maybe I'm connecting with Nina
for working on something but it's work
so we take that 25 minutes to go outside
get some sun again be with the dogs just
something that's not work to be together
if it's super freezing cold we might
just go on the balcony taking some fresh
air just something sometime to reconnect
in the middle of the day come back work
chunk number two
it's another two and a half hours on
most of whatever work chunk for the day
then we sit down this is actually a new
addition I don't think I've even talked
about this on any video or anywhere else
where I want to try to incorporate more
sit down dinner time with Nina
I haven't sat down to eat dinner I think
since I was living with my parents
something that that I did since leaving
home since I don't know 18 whatever
whenever whenever I left
um I just defaulted eating Elite while I
work I've never spent time to sit down
and actually eat
um but I wanted to use that time again
to reconnect with Nina and we carve out
it's either 25 minutes sometimes a
little bit earlier depends on how that
work chunk number two goes uh but
between five and five thirty sit down
and try not to just sit there and work
uh and you know not bring our computers
with us like actually sit at the table
and put a placemat down and and you know
silverware and
actually pretend like you're having a
real meal uh part of that may be because
we haven't gone out to a restaurant in a
year and a half
but maybe we're missing it but also time
to connect again and be together and a
lot of these moments
it doesn't have to take a long time
right the the 25 minutes with Nina in
the afternoon and then sitting down for
dinner it doesn't have to take a ton of
time but I don't know just find that
that's important to to connect
throughout the day not just at the end
then I stream so six o'clock I stream uh
zandeman uh is a co-host uh as well as
Drew and I play League of Legends which
is a video game while we take questions
from the audience about business and
life uh so you can see what we do if you
want tonight Ivan carmichael.live six
o'clock Zen's gonna bring more energy
um eight o'clock I I usually play
something with my son we're into
Minecraft right now or he's into
Minecraft right now so I'm learning
Minecraft right now Nina and I will then
watch a show uh right now we're watching
Arrow no we finished there we're
watching Flash and we're watching the
new Captain America Winter Soldier and
Falcon something like that
um 10 o'clock clean up take the dogs out
do more stretching uh take questions so
I do my 10 questions with them on
Instagram and then 11 o'clock read and
go to bed uh I'm a super slow reader my
goal is 10 pages a day if I can get that
in the half an hour then I pass out
that's a that's a daily that's my daily
to do
today we are talking about business
development how to use content to bring
in immediate business and we're going to
talk about client Outreach the first
strategy of client Outreach involves
zero content so you don't even have to
make content if you're struggling at the
point right now where like I need to
make money right now it's not working
you don't even have to make content yet
and I'm going to show you the strategy
that we've used multiple times that I've
invested into entrepreneurs and we've
done one high six figure business two
mid six figure business one low six
figure business uh that's Zach he hit
his path for six figures in three weeks
of doing this when I'm looking at Zach
or Drew or Beau or Jeremy the people
that I've invested in that we go through
this process I want at least a two
thousand dollar a month client thinking
who can pay us two thousand dollars a
month and part of the problem with a lot
of our Outreach is you're targeting
people who cannot pay you so if you're
targeting people who don't have any kind
of budget they might have a need but if
they don't have budget you're not making
money but if it's hard for them to pay
fifty dollars a month that's not an
ideal client for you so we target people
who the minimum 2000 a month and an
ideal is 3 500 plus per month okay so
I'm going to show you the process that
we go through here so Step One is make a
list of clients who can't pay you right
and what I want to do in our breakout
sessions is brainstorm together who are
the types of potential people who are
potential clients for us or partners for
us so we're making a list of clients who
can actually pay us
who can afford a thousand bucks a month
500 bucks a month 2 000 bucks a month
3500 bucks a month right uh some of the
cases it's five figures per month but
who can afford to pay you at least a
couple thousand dollars a month for the
thing you're going to be providing right
it starts to really change who we're
going often who we're targeting
so again ideally two thousand dollars
plus per month
and this is where it's often easier to
go up to businesses than it is to go
after consumers
so not a lot of individuals will be able
to pay you two thousand dollars a month
but businesses can't
if you're solving a business problem for
people and it's really helping them
it's easier to get the money because
they have budget and it's easier to
maintain it so that it's happening every
month every month every month every
month every month every month the first
brand deal that I got was I was writing
content
for a big telecommunications company
here in Canada and I was I was writing a
bunch of content and trying to sell my
content and
um through articles and wasn't making
any money and waiting on advertisements
to start to come in but you need huge
skill to do that and says okay well I
can I can write great articles and
instead of just writing for my website
instead of just writing for one person
I'm going to write for a corporate blog
and they paid me I think the first one
was 500 bucks to do a one-off and then
that led to a thousand bucks and 1500
bucks and 2 000 bucks and I kept
increasing the value and they kept
increasing how much they paid me but
because it's a business it fits in well
they have budget you're solving a
problem and
it's an ongoing problem so so they need
you to continue to ongoingly solve it
for them okay so in thinking about our
clients I want you thinking people can
actually afford to pay you part of the
biggest problem is we're not talking to
people who can actually
pay us they just don't have the budget
to pay us
okay I'm looking at Peter here he makes
these awesome
um animation videos of me you know that
he shares on Instagram cool approach
businesses and say hey I do these
animation videos
I will make a video per week for you or
per day for you or I don't know how long
it takes Peter to make these videos and
it's gonna cost two thousand bucks a
month all right we start to get clients
because we're solving a problem
okay so that's step one make a list step
two is we're gonna Outreach to them and
offer three big Ideas hey I've got three
big ideas for how you can blank so
inside of YouTube world if you're
looking at Zack or Jew or Jeremy where
we're doing YouTube Consulting with
people it's like I've got three big
ideas for how you can go from 10 000
subscribers to 100 000 subscribers or
throw out a hundred to go from a hundred
thousand to 500 000 subscribers if
they're already at 500 to go from 500
000 10 million subscribers and so on
right I've got three big ideas for how
you can get X so what is the X you can
provide people what is the result that
you're going to be able to provide
people
and you have three big ideas for how
they can accomplish that
then you reach out to them and email and
then social so email you may be able to
find their email you may not be able to
but you're looking to see if you can
find your email and then social media
wherever they are active on social
and maybe that's Twitter maybe that's
LinkedIn maybe that's Instagram who
knows maybe that's uh Tick Tock where
are they actually active themselves on
social media and then that's what we're
going to be doing some Outreach to them
to say you've got your two big ideas
that you'd love to share with them
and then you go on a call with them not
everybody says yes right this becomes a
if you only have three people on your
list that's a problem right we need to
build a big list of people so that in
the Outreach process some people will
never see it some people will ignore you
and then some people say yes and they
hop on a call and then you go through
your ideas
from that call
we're just given the value we're just
here are three big Ideas like take it
run with it go do it yourself amazing if
you need help I can help you do it too I
have a business that does this but here
are your three big Ideas so if
somebody's coming on a call to talk
about their YouTube channel to go from
50 000 subscribers to 100 here are the
three big Ideas go do it you have a team
awesome execute it yourself
I can help or Zach can help or Drew can
help or Jeremy can help right
from there you'll get 30 to 50 percent
of people who then want to sign up and
go do the thing with you if you've
targeted your list a lot
some people may not want to do it some
people may not be ready some people may
not be in the right spot yet and So for
anybody who we all hop on a call with
who then doesn't say yes right away we
add them to what we call our value
emails list and on the value emails list
every two weeks we send a value email
around the thing that they care about
Okay so
in the YouTube world uh Drew might send
an email about thumbnails right okay
here are the latest findings we have
about thumbnails or here's an experiment
that we ran on title split test or
here's how you can use your newsletter
list to grow your YouTube channel right
it's it's just value it's not hey are
you ready to buy yet hey hello I'm still
here can you hire me right so we're not
doing follow-up emails there are no
follow-up emails they they buy on the
call or they don't and if they don't
they're added to the client to the value
emails list and then every two weeks you
send a value email around the thing that
you're an expert at
just giving pure values and then the
last sentence can be hey and if you're
ready to blank right if you're ready to
grow your YouTube channel I'm happy to
help
but it's not a sales email it's a value
you're educating and you're teaching and
what some people will do
maybe they take that email and they just
do the work themselves cool they give it
to their team and say hey copy what this
person told me to do great some people
look at and say wow you're really an
expert at this and you're still giving
me tons of value I want to how can I
work with you how can I hire you and for
some people it's just a matter of timing
like they're swamped they're overwhelmed
they've got a million things going on
and they're not ready but now they are
and every time we've done this when
we've built up a list of people you hop
on some calls and some people who don't
say yes cool you add them to the list
and then you add send the value add
emails it might be somebody that you
talked to six months ago but now they're
ready
and maybe they've been seeing your
emails every two weeks or six months and
they never responded but then now they
respond and they say I'm ready
so we often get caught in this trap of
like following up and waiting for people
don't wait for people go out and do more
Outreach
and now they're getting the value adds
email every two weeks and off that list
is always somebody that you can that
comes back and says yes I was just
talking to Zach yesterday like should I
should I
drum up more business before the end of
the year it's like the easiest way to do
is just send out the value email
those people are reading the list who
know you who you've talked to who you've
done a quick audit for of their YouTube
channel send out that value email
and so what it does is keep you top of
mind the whole point here is to stay top
of mind for that you know they're
interested but it's not their most
important priority they have a million
other things that they're worried about
but in three months maybe it does become
their top priority and you've been
educating them for the past three months
over and over and over again so the
whole point is to stay top of mind so
that when they're ready you're the
person they come and they want to work
with
so the three points are make a list of
clients who can pay you this is the big
one because most of us are targeting
people who can't afford to pay us a
thousand two thousand dollars a month
offer them three big ideas on a call
and then add them to the value email
list if they don't sign up right away
today we're going to talk about
how to find where my 1 000 true fans are
hiding it's a good topic
um when I saw it pop up I was pumped
yesterday to uh start diving into some
thoughts I love the Pullman system we
created I really love it I love that you
guys are giving feedback on what you
want to talk about and we're pulling
some of the things from the book but
then also what I really love about this
group is I can share my my current best
practices like what am I doing exactly
right now so a lot of the examples I'm
going to share are just what I was doing
yesterday you know when you write a book
you want it to last right so you can't
always share exactly what you're doing
right now because it's going to change
in six months it's going to change in a
year it's going to change in five years
right I want people in 10 years to still
read this book and find it valuable but
the the value of this group is you get
you get the access to exactly right now
what I'm working on so it's always so
much fun putting these together for you
so let's dive in so how to find where my
1 000 true fans are hiding
has always giving a shout out to who
came up with this topic Mr Ben McNeil I
don't know if Ben's in the house I was
in the house yet I haven't seen you Ben
if you're in the house say hi walk
aboard thank you for the awesome topic
so how to find where my 1 000 true fans
are hiding so number one they're not
hiding you are when I first saw this
topic I was excited but also a little a
little tiny bit put off just in the
warning because I want you guys to
always take 100 accountability Right
This is How I Live it's my fault it's my
responsibility to get out there and make
the progress that I want and the
beginning is great right how to how to
seeking answers you're looking you're
searching you're trying to find it but
that last part of hiding
they're not hiding right that's putting
that's putting you know the blame and
responsibility on them they're not
hiding for for too many of us it's it's
you right like you're hiding you're not
posting enough content you're not
sharing your story enough you're not
putting yourself out there you're not
creating enough
right and I know I know it's hard and
we'll talk about some of the ideas here
later on in this in this presentation
but
um
if you're not where you want to be yet
it's it's a direct result of your effort
your abilities your skill set your
putting in the work right but I just
wanted to to
highlight in the language and I I know
this wasn't Ben's intent I know Ben in
post in it was not saying it's their
fault but just just being careful about
the word choice that we're using and the
stories that we're telling ourselves
because
they're not hiding the problem is not
that your fans are hiding the problem is
that you're hiding and we need to
unleash that and that's that part in the
book that's part of this program it's
part of this presentation
um and so I'm super excited to
help unleash that so I know sharing is
scary
talk about it in the book
um whenever I say BTS has built the
server page 108 if you want more
references you can go in and check it
out I have this picture of me and Alex
up because we discovered uh last week or
two weeks ago that Alex has a learning
disability
uh
one ADHD which is super common but also
something called executive functioning
anyway and it's been it's been hurting
he's you know had it his whole life just
kind of figured it out now uh he learns
slower than most people things that I
don't have to repeat to others I have to
go over multiple times with him before
he finally gets it and now we're trying
to devise kind of strategies and
techniques and how we can learn more
effectively but what I told them
yesterday and this is why I love this
group is I can share what's happening
right now yesterday was Alex you have to
share that story you have to share that
you have a learning disability you have
to share how that makes you feel you
have to share the impact that is having
on you trying to be an entrepreneur or
trying to build the business trying to
live your life how does it hit you
because other people will connect to
that right and and he he doesn't know
how to process it yet he's worried about
you know judgment and how people see it
uh he you know wants to talk to his mom
first and all this stuff but in sharing
is the thing that will make people
connect to you
and so he's already shared his stories
about
hyperhidrosis and and being the
excessive sweating and
um not being able to talk to girls and
all this stuff and a lot of it is in is
in the book but this just happened you
know last week and yesterday was my
conversation with him about you have to
share this with your audience and that's
actually part of the healing
that is actually part of the healing
because as long as you're worried about
it as long as you're afraid of the
judgment and what people might say about
it you keep it hidden you keep yourself
plain small and then you don't create
any amazing content and that secret owns
you
and so I told them great go talk to your
mom awesome but then you have to go post
he's like well should I post it as a
story should I post it as Instagram live
like it doesn't matter just get it out
there
just get it out there so that somebody
watches it and gives you some kind of
comment I mean the comments are all
going to be positive right nobody's
going to come on and say Alex I never
knew you were a dummy right at least I
hope not
but in sharing it and getting the secret
out there it's it's incredibly
empowering and other people will then be
inspired as well to talk to Alex about
their learning disability and be able to
share in their life the things that are
happening so this is part of the hiding
this is part of the hiding that we all
go through is the story that you're
afraid to share is the thing that you
have to share to help people connect to
you it makes sense logically it's just
difficult
it's difficult to share the thing that
you don't want other people to know
it's still hard like Alex has gone
through this Alex has been around me for
five years so he knows this but it's
still hard right so that's fine it's
meant to be hard
but getting it out there becomes the
healing process
in in Bill to serve page 63 talk about
being the tree and so my my concept of
the tree is
um the tree is designed to breathe in
uh carbon dioxide right which is too
much for a human is poison it eats it it
grows cement and then it spits out
oxygen
for the world and I see that as our job
as thought leaders as movement makers is
your job is partly to eat the negativity
to eat the criticism to eat the judgment
to grow from it and then spit out oxygen
positivity for the world for the people
who currently are who you used to be
and so when I say they're not hiding you
are what I want to see is more
consistency more vulnerability more
personal storytelling more effort and
care right more more more and more and
it may not you may not have great
results yet you may not be proud of the
finished product yet because you're
still learning still getting better
still trying but all of these things the
more you the more you can apply them
more you can become that tree the more
you're sharing your story
you're going to find that the people
your thousand true fans suddenly come
out of air quotes hiding
right they come out of hiding because
you've given them permission to
because for them to come out of hiding
you need to come out of hiding first
does that make sense
uh Joshua saying my favorite
illustration was the tree
yeah I don't know where that came from
um
it was off I was doing some podcast and
uh it was with uh somebody who was into
like psychedelics and and crazy stuff
um and I and I told him that he's a tree
and then I said you know what that's a
great that's a great analogy anyway okay
so I don't know if Ben is here Ben
saying hi if you're here I might have
missed it if you are but um so Ben and
this is not meant to be a knock at Ben
right Ben I went to his Facebook account
and he posted once three days ago and
then one six days ago and and maybe he's
posting somewhere else I couldn't find
his Instagram or anything else but uh
this is where now we need to step up
right this is part of the hiding if
we're posting two times in six days if
you want to be a thought leader and and
get your message out there it has to be
more frequently right back to here more
consistency more vulnerability more
personal story telling more effort and
care so if I'm running Ben's page here I
want to I want to see those things I
want to see the consistency right so six
times in six days right I want to see
the storytelling right here it's just
telling me about a new podcast and what
does it say new podcast with Naomi
awesome uh use a discounted code to get
prices awesome I mean
there's no vulnerability there there's
no storytelling I'm sure the podcast
itself is great but tell me in the
content that you're posting right and so
more care more effort more storytelling
more more vulnerability more consistency
that's how you pull them out of hiding
by you leading by example
that making sense
and and I love Ben this isn't this again
is not meant to be a knock against Ben
or or any of you guys have just pulled
his profile as an example I bet if I
went into a lot of your profiles would
be something similar and and I want you
to take the accountability and start
creating the content that you need to to
track the people to build your movement
of the impact you want to have
we are live movement makers I'm going to
do something a little different today
I'm excited it's gonna be a little bit
different this is either going to be the
greatest thing of all time or or Flop so
I don't know until you until you try and
experiment I was looking at the topics
and most of the topics that we've
covered so far have been
uh fairly easy to turn into a slide deck
and then talk about them and answer
questions and give you some context as
we go along the way and I try to inject
some of the new things that I'm working
on uh through it and I looked at the
topics you know Outreach email nurture
list that's easy to make into a deck how
to help our world have more peace and
love I love that topic you guys didn't
vote that up but but uh so we're not
doing that but that that's that's also
something that can be turned into a deck
the how to make money one though I
thought would actually be better to turn
this into a strategy session with you
guys I mean I cover it in built to serve
right we talk about the three different
things and I'll touch on it quickly uh
but the fact that that's the number one
most voted topic I want to go deeper
with you I want to I want to use this
time together to really understand what
you're trying to work on and how we can
turn your current projects into making
more money for you
um it's it's why I wrote the book is yes
to figure out your purpose but to turn
it into something that you can make into
the business and support your your
yourself your family your community all
of it quickly and built to serve I cover
three different areas and again we can
dive as deep as you want into these the
first one is the fast fast Freedom right
and so that the idea is you're creating
content on your channel uh all your
social accounts you have your 10 pack of
content
I go through it in here we can talk more
in depth if you want but basically that
acts as a as a marketing brochure for
you so that when people hit your social
media accounts they say huh this person
knows what they're talking about they
get me they're like me uh but they're a
little bit further ahead I'd like to
work with this person great it actually
is your marketing brochure then what
you're doing is Outreach right then
you're you're reaching 50 to 100 people
a day DM and then message them uh get
involved in relevant conversations uh
offering to help and then they're going
to go to your uh to your page see what
you can do and
set up your first call
that's a lot of grunt work that's a lot
of hand-to-hand combat right there's a
lot of you 50 to 100 times a day
reaching out and dming people most
people won't even see it most people
won't reply but then you get people who
do and that's that's the train to start
building the momentum
um the second path is through
Partnerships and referrals right so you
find the people who can actually move
the needle for you who already have your
target audience and you find a way to
try to start working with them
uh so what Evan just did as an example
on uh in in this post recently where he
said he was doing you know he got on a
call there were people in there he did
his presentation and somebody wanted to
hire him as a result right whoever LED
that call with all those people in it
that's a perfect example of a partner
relationship so you think who already
has my target audience how can I connect
with them to provide value
um and then get in there and start
making a relationship and then the third
strategy is through thought leadership
and that's content and that's ongoing
and that's where I spend a good chunk of
the book because people
uh struggle and people that make good
thought leadership content
um and so guiding through how to make
content Beyond just the first 10 pack of
content
and staying consistent and picking the
platforms and turning your thoughts your
expertise into a lead magnet that that
ongoing keeps bringing in Revenue
attention traffic interest for you I
want to share two quick examples of
people who I've mentored and trained
who've gone through this process
uh from scratch right from zero it's
easy to look at what I'm doing and say
wow
you know you've already had all this
traction you've been on YouTube for 11
years and all this stuff but from
scratch uh two people who I mentored uh
one was Lily and one was Jeremy and Lily
uh wanted to be a speaker and she came
here and said I want to be a speaker I
want to speak on stage and so you know
we quickly got her a tedx speech
um and that was her very very first
speaking gig but then I said hey if you
want to be a great speaker you actually
have to be a great uh one-on-one you
gotta you gotta do coaching whether you
want to be a coach long term or are you
just using that as a platform to become
a better speaker because if you're going
to speak you have to think about it as
not speaking to an audience of a
thousand people or 100 people or 20
people but a hundred individual people a
thousand individual people and what
makes you a better speaker is having
worked one-on-one with so many people
because if you're just given a message
you don't feel how it bounces back when
you're working with somebody and you say
go do this they say yeah but yeah but
yeah but
and that doesn't come out when you're
speaking on stage so if you know what
the yacht butts are going to be because
you've worked with enough people
uh that turns you into a much better
speaker because you can address it from
stage so I told her to do this and at
the beginning she didn't even know how
to coach people so it also depends what
level of expertise you have coming in
she knew nothing and so I said you know
what take the take the one word
framework my first book your one word
and go off and start helping people
figure out their one word
um she believed in it she you know she
connected with it so that became what
she was doing and she did her first I
want to say 75 to 100 calls for free
absolutely just reaching out people who
are uh following me people who are uh
anybody who commented on any of her
posts
um anybody she was going live every day
and she did 75 to 100 calls for free
absolutely free
just to build momentum just to get the
experience as a coach because she wasn't
very good because she didn't know she
was doing yet now she got a lot better
and then she started charging the first
the indication of you're ready to start
making money is do people ask you hey
can I hire you back if you do a free
session how many people are then saying
can I can I hire you can we go deeper
can can you help me can I learn more
um until you get there then you haven't
done a good enough job it might have
been okay it's great but it wasn't
enough that they say I really love this
person this person can make an impact
and so that's why getting the practice
out even on things like Instagram live
is fantastic practice because it's free
and it's more exposure and showing you
coaching is a great chance to get people
to
uh then say oh can I hire you can I work
with you right every time I go live on
Instagram I get DMS of people saying Hey
how do I hire you how do I work with you
how can I it's like that's not the
business I want to be in but I could be
if if I was starting from zero and I had
a job and was trying to get this thing
off the ground I would do a lot more
coaching and one-on-one work because
that can help pay the bills to get you
to where you need to go so
the first person then said Hey how do I
hire you Lily in
uh she said oh my God I don't even know
how to charge for this so we started off
low you know it was 25 bucks an hour for
the first 10 people uh and then once you
hit 10 people 25 it became 50 bucks an
hour for the next 10 people and then
once you hit 10 people became 75 bucks
an hour for the next 10 people and then
100 bucks an hour for the next 10 people
and and kept scaling up and scaling up
now this is taking a person who's got a
lot of heart a lot of care a lot of love
but no skill set yet not an expert at
what she does and so it's building that
up
uh so it took some time but it was
really just a matter of doing enough
Outreach getting enough calls getting
that practice in that could have been a
lot faster if she was crushing from the
very first call right but she had to put
in the Reps to get better the other one
is Jeremy and Jeremy has helped to build
the YouTube Consulting business so
you know he's he's coming up on one year
I think it was July that he started uh
charging money for it and it's
six-figure business business in one year
and he
I taught him basically everything about
YouTube he's he's still learning from me
I mean he just messaged me this morning
or just before going live here there's
been a conversation back and forth about
one of his clients and he took all of my
learnings
and started to then reach out to people
to say
hey uh thought leaders especially you've
got this YouTube channel I want to help
I've got three big ideas that can I
think help blow you up uh I'd love to
hop on a call and and help you and help
go through the ideas uh
we started when I got back from my tour
last year and
I said okay dude you got to do you know
five calls for free
just to see just to see how much you
picked up I gave them homework go
research go learn go watch these
channels go digest everything I've ever
said about YouTube and he did he did the
homework he came back and the call was
actually the first call we did was way
better than I thought it was going to be
because before
you know I put my name on something I
want to make sure that it's going to be
high quality going up I'm not saying hey
you know we've helped Evan Carmichael
build his channel uh we're gonna use
your his strategies and apply to yours
got to make sure that it's actually you
know he's representative brand well
um so it's been all Outreach
um I I haven't been on a single sales
call with him I helped him land
maybe maybe two two of his deals
um now he's using my name to go off and
get deals but it's mostly just Outreach
and it's him on the call on me giving a
little bit of mentorship behind the
scenes uh and you know 100 100K Plus in
the first year
um that's great service based business
and so
it really just depends it's definitely a
volume give getting out there this is if
you're selling coaching or Consulting
Services uh and it depends on how good
you are you know Jeremy was really good
and had a leg up because I was I was
teaching him and mentoring him
but I took a guy who was Jeremy was when
I got him a grocery store clerk
he was stocking shelves at a grocery
store and I just saw something in them
said hey I want to start a YouTube
Consulting business with you you have to
go off and learn all this stuff and um
he said yes and so far it's worked out
great and he's keeping the up up the
level of clients right so his first
client was 500 bucks a month and then it
became a thousand and then 2 000 and now
he's up to three and a half thousand or
thirty six hundred something like that a
month for some of his clients
and it's awesome and so that that's
what's possible taking somebody from a
grocery store clerk who knows nothing
about the stuff to quickly learning and
going off lending deals and getting
clients if you want to watch the full
version of this video as well as train
live with me twice a month to help you
build your movement and be around some
other amazing people just like you check
out my movement makers program the link
to join is right there next to me I
can't wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join